While this one is called a histogram, this one is called a bar graph. The spaces
in between the columns here mean that each of these is one distinct category.
Europe is completely distinct from North America, completely distinct from Asia
and we can't mix them. But with age, we can choose any interval or bin size. And
so, that's the next really important difference. You can change the bin size for
age data but not for the country data. We could make our bins from 0 to 80, in
which case, all the students would be in that one bin. But we can't do the same
for this unless we make it world, or something different, we could divide it
into hemispheres but we're still more restricted with this type of data then
with the age data. And finally, the order of the continents doesn't really
matter. However, age is just in one order, from least to greatest. With the bar
graph, we might choose to put it into a particular order depending on what
question we're trying to answer. Such as where are most students from? Then, we
might put it in a order from least to greatest or greatest to least. Or, we
might choose to alphabetize it so that viewers can easily find what continent or
country or whatever they're looking for on the x-axis. And finally, the shape of
a histogram is very important. Whereas, the shape of a bar graph is arbitrary,
depending on how you choose to order the categories on the x-axis. One thing to
remember is that with a histogram, the variable on the x-axis is numerical and
quantitative. Whereas with a bar graph, the variable on the x-axis is often
categorical or qualitative.